have you ever had an addiction yes I've
had several Jada pinkett-smith opens up
about her struggles with addiction I'm
hoping that it will give people the
freedom also in their lives to find
their truth the 46 year old actress got
extremely candid on the latest episode
of her hit Facebook watch series red
Tabletalk where she revealed her
addiction to sex my sort of addictions
jump they jump around when I was younger
I definitely think I had a sex addiction
some kind yes that everything could get
be fixed by sex yes you know what I'm
saying is the behavior that's attached
to it cuz this if you wanna have a lot
of sex that's great but why are you
having all that sex that's what you
gotta lick you know what I mean sex
wasn't the only obstacle she's faced now
became a gym addict I was just in the
gym constantly just and then I remember
reaching a rock bottom that time I was
in the house by myself and I had those
two bottles of wine and was going for
the third bottle and it was like now
hold up you in this house by yourself
going on to your third that's gangster
bottle of wine Jada says she was able to
combat the issues herself
I went cold turkey that's the thing
about me I can go cold turkey I am a
Binger and I always have to watch myself
and just how I can get just obsessed
with things and you know it's not what
you're doing about how you're with it
right why are you doing it one of the
kind of downfalls to celebrity is that
you kind of fall into a space where you
think you have to be a certain thing for
other people and I've just gotten into
my life into a place in my life where
I'm ready to dissolve all that you know
and
and be more of what I am truly and I
don't know if people are ready but I
know I am